على الناس التفرقه بين الحقيقه وما
يشاهدونه يجب على الناس معرفه هؤلاء الذين
استخدموا العنف و تلطخت ايديهم بالدماء
بما فيهم الجيش المصري الجيش المصري تعرض
للارهاب وشهد كل هذا من البدايه الحقيقه
المزعومه التي شهدناها على قناتكم وغيرها
ليست الحقيقه باكملها فلقد اقترحنا كل
الطرق السلميه المحتمله لمعالجه هذا
الموضوع اها الرئيس السابق محمد البرادعي
بخيانته للثقه الوطنيه لاستقالته بعد
الحمله على انصار مرسي فهل تؤيد هذا
الاتهام لا اؤيد اعتقد ان محمد البرادعي
لديه وجهه نظره الخاصه فانا والكثير من
الناس في مصر يحترمونه ولكن معظمهم شعروا
انهم لم يفهموا قرار استقالته بهذه
السرعه
هل تظن انه قد تخوف مما راه لا اعتقد انه
خاف ولكن البرادعي شخص مثالي انه بمثابه
غندي او مانديلا في مصر فقد قال انه يرى
حلا لهذا من غير اي مواجهات ولكن الحقيقه
والواقع هو انه قد توجهنا نحو طريق لم
يرده احد الاخوان المسلمون دفعو لاتخاذ
هذا الطريق نحن نحترم رايه ولذلك يجب عليه
احترام راي
الاخرين لنتكلم عن السياحه اذا نظرنا الى
الاحصائيات خلال السنه الماضيه فهي شبه
محبطه فلقد ارتفع عدد السياح الى ما يقارب
ال 14 مليون عام 2010 قبل الثوره وفي
تقرير اخر ذكر ان معدل حجز تذاكر السفر
الى مصر قد هبط بنسبه 4% في صيف 2013 اما
الفنادق فقد هبطت النسبه بواقع 15% فما هي
رسالتك للسياح كيف بامكانك التاكيد انهم
سيكونون
بمامن
اولا الوضع امن جدا في شوارع مصر حاليا
وثانيا المشكله بين المصريين فقط وسياح
الاجانب ليسوا طرفا فيها فهي مشكله داخليه
يعتمد حلها على المصريين
انفسهم